I saw the stat that Travis Kelce plays
better when Taylor swiftz is in
attendance Travis Kel is my boy best
tied end in the league for like the past
3 four years so it's obviously not
Taylor Swift but I'mma tell yall one
thing when there is a bad girl and she's
in attendance and she's watching you
there gives you an extra boost of
confidence when you pull up to the gym
and your girl's with you I don't care
who's in front of me like without a
doubt in my mind kawi Leonard could be
in front of me I got to give him 30 I
refused to go in that car on the way
home and my girl is talking about damn
he dropped you off today huh nah that's
Happ so you know what Kel is doing I
know what's going on he was already
doing it so now it's like yeah I'm I'm
going to do it more now like it's a
Swagger it's a confidence when that
things happens y know how it go come on
now PE